hi there my name is reto Meier and i'm
ian ni-lewis this week we find out
what's up with SMS replacement app
whatsapp messenger we take a bite out of
the group meet for beta see if we like
the new flavor is that it tastes a lot
less like fruit than it used to a lot
more like ice cream man we discovered
that instant messaging classic trillion
has only supply survived the apocalyptic
instant messaging Wars of the early
2000s but has risen from the ashes to
flourish in the mobile space all that
and more this week on the app clinic ah
this week we're looking at instant
messaging apps which turns out to be a
critical part of mine and IANS team
workflow yeah what you may not realize
is that reto and I never speak directly
on one another in fact we don't even
ever be in the same room we're actually
in opposite sides of building 44 right
now that's right ratos not here at all
so that means i am apps are critical for
us to get things done let's stop by
looking at what's app whatsapp messenger
was by far our most popular candidate
this week absolutely yeah and you can
see here that they've got have done a
pretty good job on their landing page on
Google Play it's one of the things that
they've done a little bit wrong here so
they've got a great logo which I really
like to see but what they've done which
I think they could really improve on is
their feature graphic which is
effectively just a combination of their
logo the app name in a bunch of
screenshots now it turns out that there
are other places on the Google Play
listing for your logo app name and
screenshots and so it's kind of a wasted
space so they've they've done the right
thing and having a feature graphic but
they could do a lot more with what God
sure so what is this app it describes
itself as a super-powered replacement
for SMS messaging and I'd say it pretty
much lives up to that claim you can do
all the regular instant messaging type
behavior that expect which is basically
sending into the messages to other
people all without having to rely on a
cell network connection in order to do
so so the big plus here is that if you
don't have an unlimited text messaging
plan you can send messages to your
friends at no cost which is nice
as a bonus you can also do multimedia
stuff so you can send pictures images
videos movies all of that sort of stuff
which you can theoretically do with with
mms but this makes it a lot easier and
of course it also supports offline
messaging which is nice they try and
keep things as simple as possible by
tying everything into your phone number
rather than having a secondary account
which is nice but it does mean you can't
use this app on tablet devices and sure
enough they've actually blocked
installation for those those platforms
which is a little bit a little bit
disappointing frankly because it really
does limit the utility of the app and
given that it's transferring data over
the Internet why force me to depend on
having a mobile number having a device
with a a mobile connection so as you can
see from this screenshot I think what's
that message you could really do with a
full UI overhaul really bringing it up
to date with hollow themes and genuinely
presenting a more consistent and
intuitive UI navigation structure I'm
not going to go too much detail into
that that's kind of Romans wheelhouse
I'm going to let him in the guys comment
more on that aspect on Tuesdays Android
design in action I think we do have to
say that skeuomorphic is fine but it's
pretty old-school to just slap some sort
of random picture behind you slowly
absolutely i mean if you using
skeuomorphism as a technique to try and
make fuses more comfortable with the app
so that they feel more familiar with the
expectations then that's a great idea
here it just looks like white and black
backgrounds look kind of boring let's
stick something behind maybe a faux rock
effect and that frankly doesn't really
add to it it just makes the whole thing
a little bit untidy true so the elevator
pitch for group me is that it's like
your own private twitter and I think
that's a pretty accurate description
awesome my fault sorry no no no it's
cool take your time all right we've used
group me a lot on the Android team when
we go to a conference like Google i/o
it's tough to stay in sync with whole
team and if you don't stay in touch now
you miss things like the hundred dollar
shots of glenrothes that Dan Galpin
missed had a high of 2012 that was a
good night and thanks Shannon we will
pay you back someday anyway groovy isn't
perfect but so far it's been the most
reliable solution for keeping our group
in sync it works via push messaging but
it can also send messages via mms SMS so
it works even if you don't have a data
plan and that's pretty important if
you're in Shanghai or Barcelona or so
paulo oh the I 280 between Cupertino and
sunny though well that's true yeah
there's some sort of I don't know rip in
the fabric of reality down there that
disturbs anything that gets too close
speaking of which group me used to look
like this which made it feel a lot less
like an Android app and the speech
bubbles not only make me feel like I've
accidentally picked up someone else's
device some hipsters device they also
waste space and clash with the Android
action bar at the top of the screen the
redesigns better use of space and feels
a lot more like Android it's even got
some nice touches like the embedded map
view and that's great for finding out
where the party is in fact I remember in
barthelona we we were trying to find the
party for see how long was it Dan was
like ours right walking around for hours
yeah and we couldn't find it but in
Buffalo know everywhere is a party like
just open the next the nearest door that
is true but we were looking for a
specific part though the great ragers
yeah we didn't want to get fired let's
just put it down I didn't want to be
like that and miss out on the free booze
exactly well my only objection to the
redesign is the way they've changed the
action bar so Grimmie has jumped on the
drawer bandwagon so not only do they
take away the regular up affordance but
they also got this this 3 bar thing that
I guess is starting to be acknowledged
as the universal drawer pattern but I'm
still a fan of the up affordance and
apparently they didn't get the memo
about the design guidelines for
roars just in case you're in the same
boat here is the memo the main takeaway
is a drawer should slide out under the
action bar not push the action bar out
of the way that's important because your
action bar is still needs to be
contextual it's still your up affordance
a we don't want it to arbitrarily leave
the screen but let's not get too caught
up in the design that's really Romans
job let's go ahead and move on overall
the beta looks like groomy is moving in
a great direction I love the way they've
worked with media a lot of the
recommendations that we've given about
using larger pictures and alpha text
over the pictures just make it look
fantastic honestly the the only thing
that I really really wish that they grew
me did is an easier login now they've
actually changed made a big change for
the better in the previous version you
had to log in with your phone number
which for me was a horrible issue not
only do i use google voice and not have
like 10 different sims that i use i can
never remember which phone number
actually logged into group me with first
i think was something that I threw away
long time ago but their SMS permission
system where they'll actually they'll
send you a text to say is this really
your phone it doesn't always work and I
don't know why I had that problem today
actually yeah it might be that because
of their beta this servers are just
under load or something anyway they made
it so you can login with the username
and password but if you've been watching
the show you know what my pet peeve is
here don't make me type in a username
and a password my credentials are on the
phone either put the account on the
phone or synchronize or federate an
account that's already there Google Play
services makes this easy we talked about
that a couple weeks ago you know typing
in passwords is so 2010 don't make me do
it all right let's go ahead and move on
all right so I think the biggest
surprise for me with trillion is that it
actually still existed and I mean that
it's kind of a
compliment it's great to see company
able to leverage their core strengths
and really take advantage of new
opportunities when they arise and that's
really exactly what the team a trillion
has done so in the height of the instant
messaging Federation was Gillian was my
go-to client for being able to connect
to multiple services at once i was on
icq i had friends who were on what other
ones existed yahoo i don't know there
was a very well Lillian's heaps of them
and so truly was a great way to have one
app that lived on my desktop PC at that
time was let me communicate with
everyone because you know that was the
only way we could get things done was to
have clients through the Federation for
us now these days they've taken it a
step further and they've added support
for some of the newer protocols like
Facebook instant messaging I think skype
is either there or on that road map and
of course with most of these
conversations now happening from
people's phones it's great to see
trillion offering a mobile app so rather
than being a replacement for SMS
messaging like the the two apps we
looked at earlier trilogy trillion is
really looking to replace the need for
having a number of separate chat clients
for each of the different services that
you already use so it's supposed to
replace having to have four or five
different interests messaging clients
and they've done a great job of keeping
things simple and you can see that on
the screen shot here and if you go
through the app it it really is sort of
that cut down most basic version of how
instant messaging apps used to work you
have a list of contacts in this case
separated by the service type so you can
see who your icq friends are which kind
of doesn't make that much sense because
I don't really care what technology i'm
using what back-end service i'm using to
communicate with people i just want to
see the people and communicate with them
and I guess the complexity here is that
often people will have multiple accounts
on each of the different services so how
do you reconcile that and I think that's
one of the challenges and something
which an app like trillion could really
perhaps put in a little bit more effort
to figure out how to do that
reconciliation otherwise the simplicity
is nice but really the app just looks a
little dated I could really do with an
upgrade to holo styling and even better
I'd really love to see them try and
develop a rich tablet user experience to
complement their desktop and mobile apps
so again this is an app which was
designed for mobile so take advantage of
the
fact that people were sending their
instant messages over SMS buy a
blackberry messenger and other mobile
devices and so they've made a mobile app
as well I'd love to see them now realize
that you know tablets aware it's out as
well and develop some some tablet app
features too just like one of those
things where they could really take
advantage of the contact manager you
know it but having having people have
icq and Facebook and other different
types of accounts it's really just like
having a friend that has a work phone
and a home phone and cell phone exactly
and that's exactly what the contact
contract content provider lets you do so
you can add your own specific content
types and in this case it would be
different instant messaging clients and
sleep i'm not mistaken i think instant
messaging clients is one of the default
fields you can use so there may be
better off just leveraging that existing
infrastructure definitely definitely i
think that would make me a lot happier
although it always makes me happy
whenever you have to say contracts
contacts contracts provider fun area
that's I'd you can do it better than I
do well you know well about practice so
let's go ahead and dive into a couple of
details that we think would help instant
messaging apps in general if I had to
pick one feature that is absolutely
crucial for an instant messaging app
that one thing that you really just
cannot afford to get wrong it's
notifications mmm the whole point of
instant messaging is it's instant you
need to know as soon as a message
arrives at the same time it's also
crucial to use notifications wisely all
right it's terrible to have too many
notifications it's worse than having
none at all so that's why on any version
of Android no matter what you're running
you should always make sure you're doing
what we call stacking notifications I
sort of don't like the word stacking
notifications because it it could
actually refer to the wrong way of doing
things in my opinion but here's what the
design guide means when we talk about
stacking of cases if you have two
notifications that would otherwise be
displayed on top of one another the
basic rule of thumb is that your apps
should never appear more than once in
the notification panel so if you have
something new to say then say it inside
your existing notification rather than
creating a second note of case
for instance you can add a number
pending feel to let your users know that
there's more see you know instead of
stacking they're placing three
notifications in the notification panel
you just display one that says you have
three notifications pending but if
you're running on jelly bean or higher
you can actually do a lot better than
that the standard notification builder
class has a new style it's called in
back style lets you add a list of
strings to your notification so when the
notification gets expanded the user can
see all their recent notifications at a
glance you can see that in the gmail app
for instance i think you know if you
look at this particular style view on
the right there where it's expanded i
think you can see that's a perfect way
to receive a series of instant messages
you might also consider going one step
further with rich notifications and have
some action buttons for instance i
honestly would really appreciate a
button to automatically send a busy
message from i am i am buddy you know
i'm driving or whatever just something
that's that's really really simple of
course i'm in a meeting right list
dangers yeah well anyway the point is
that there's a lot of stuff you can do
with rich notifications on jellybean but
you don't actually have to be targeting
jellybean to get this if you use a
notification compat api it's easy to
support both the old notification style
and the new hotness just remember that
any action buttons you create won't be
available on legacy versions of the OS
so you need to have some alternate way
to access that behavior and of course as
we all know it's usually to just tap the
notification and send these are directly
to an activity that can handle that
notification or expand on it or offer
actions so using the notification compat
api you're right actually able to just
have a single code path which has all
the functionality for all the newest
versions and it just gracefully degrades
back to whatever supported essentially
so yeah it's nice that's question yeah
that's really cool so the the code that
you see on the screen is ripped from the
pages of developer android com and shows
you exactly how to make
an inbox style notification as you can
see it's really quite simple and I think
I think in fact the if you go to Android
training or perhaps the API guides the
notification guide i think is being
recently updated to have all the new
hotness explained in some detail so yes
in fact that's where i stole all the
previous I've done graphics from yes I
have been thieving like a madman today
that's what we do here in as developer
advocates we take all the hard work of
our tech writers and steal it and pass
it up as our exactly life is good what
do you have for us today or ito well I
think it's also worth discussing how
these instant messaging apps actually
work the key to a great experience is
really balancing that low latency
instant instant messaging with making
sure that you're not draining the
battery in order to get that those rapid
updates so fundamentally there's a
couple of different approaches that you
can take on the first hand you can
maintain an open socket connection
between your client running on each
device and your server now having an
open socket will minimize your latency
because the connection is there you can
just sense it off through that pipe but
you really need to carefully manage it
so that you're not draining your battery
exceptionally quickly by maintaining
that socket so the way that you actually
keep the socket open is by sending data
or sending keep-alive pings to your
server at regular intervals which is
going to stop the network from
automatically closing those sockets but
if your ping to regularly you're just
going to be keeping the cell radio
turned on its going to drain the battery
and if you do it too infrequently you
can lose your socket connection anyway
so the latency is going to go up because
you're expecting it to be zero latency
but it isn't you've got the additional
costs it takes to initiate a new soccer
connection it's just a bad time
all-round figuring out the right
frequency is actually really really hard
it varies between network operators the
sockets that you're allowed to use to
have these long-lived connections vary
depending on networks so you know it
makes it really difficult for individual
app developers to figure out and frankly
that's not the sort of thing that you
want to have to be thinking about you
want to be focusing on features on you I
not how do I keep the data connection
going between the app and server you
know not only that but even if you got
everything right in order to avoid
draining the battery and keep the socket
open and get all the be
a viewer that you want you would also
have to synchronize perfectly with any
other app that wanted to do this right
because even if let's say ten minutes is
a magic number right my appt goes every
10 minutes your app goes every 10
minutes your apps start at five minutes
after mine ouch whoopsie so how can we
do that then so how can we synchronize
all of the apps on the device that they
all send pings at the same time well I
think you've got to have somebody sing
the pants and the pings for you exactly
and happily that is exactly what Google
Cloud messaging does so we've already
figured out the most efficient way to
maintain a low latency network path and
in fact this is something that we can
keep track of and continue it to
optimize and make more and more
efficient so then you can just pee back
on top of that and use it as a mechanism
to tell your app when it should initiate
a new connection and start transferring
those messages in real time so all of
the details for Google Cloud messaging
are available on that cloud sync android
training class so the thing is there's
that cloud to device messaging while
c2dm as we like to call it because
everyone loves an acronym doesn't
guarantee the delivery latency you will
definitely get there but you don't know
that it'll get there straight away now
chances are it will get there straight
away but one approach to is actually use
c2dm to initiate the conversation so
when someone pings you with a message
the first time you see to the M to
notify the recipient who can then create
a short-lived socket connection to
transfer the the rapid-fire messages
backwards and forwards so then you're
just keeping a short-lived socket you
kill it as soon as the conversation is
finished and then fall back to waiting
for c2dm to to wake up your app and
listen for new messages so some apps
that we looked at actually chose to use
a third option which is really an option
which is pulling the server just pinging
you server to check to see whether
you've got any new messages pending and
that's kind of a terrible idea because
the latency is going to be shocking
unless you're doing it every minute in
which case the battery drain is going to
be even more shocking than the latency
and I saw some comments in reviews
suggesting that that's what whatsapp
messenger does
to you know to get it to get its
messages though I open confirmed that so
I don't want to criticize them too
sharply without knowing for certain but
if that is the case and that's
definitely something you want to move
away from and move towards a GCM model
so if you have your own servers pawling
is never the right answer so if you're
relying on someone else's servers to to
get information so you can't send a push
message well okay then you're gonna have
to come up with something clever but if
you've got your own servers then this is
going to make your life a lot easier so
yeah switch to GCM the Sun will shine
brighter food will taste sweeter and
life will in always be better I switched
to GCM I liked it so much i bought the
company so before we sign off let's take
a look at prescriptions for each of the
apps that we have looked at today and
say we can't help them move towards a
more pure Android experience so start
off with with whatsapp messenger hey so
I think first off what I'd really like
to see is a tablet support I'd love to
see them make this app work really
nicely create an optimized tablet
experience I think that's something
which is kind of missing from this space
where a lot of the focus has been on
creating this awesome mobile experience
because that's clearly where their
growth is tablets seemed like the next
logical step you know when you're
sitting on your couch rather than
opening up your laptop to instant
messaging people you can have a richer
experience talking to more than one
person using a tablet so I was surprised
at how common it was for some of these
messaging apps to rely on SMS if not as
their only transport mechanism then at
least as their primary mechanism and
that really feels like five years ago it
does it's it kind of makes it made sense
back when hey we can simplify sign up by
just checking what the phone number is
but now it's actually complicates it
because half of my devices don't have a
sim card in them I've got tablets I've
got devices without Sims so you know
it's really just makes my life harder so
an on phone signup flow for what's that
messenger would make my life a lot
better I'd love to see modernized you I
I'd love to see some using
cloud-to-device messaging if they're not
already doing so
yeah in the future none of us will have
phone numbers you're going to be able to
ring my email address I would like to do
that yeah that would make me a happier
person what did you think about group me
well group me is in beta and the beta
looks really really promising it's hard
to say for sure exactly how it's going
to turn out yeah there's definitely some
rough edges right now but I there like
the idea of beta releases to try and
figure out where you should be investing
that time and effort to get the best
bang for your buck right absolutely in
fact the only thing that disappointed me
about the betas I couldn't get it off of
Google Play I had to go to their website
and get it but that's that's not their
fault that's probably ours now it would
be nice if we offered a way to do more
streamlined beta release via google play
but you know what I put that on a
request let's do that I know some people
excellent I the drawer pattern is
definitely done in let's say that not
the wrong way that it's the wrong it's
it's an experimental way experiment
which went wrong it's it's not the way
that we recommend right now and so I I'd
like to see him fix that they also have
this sort of we didn't really touch on
this but they've got this sort of weird
thing where the drawer actually opens
either to the left or to the right
making it almost but not quite like a
view pager so they've they've sort of
mixed a few metaphors and I think that
as they sort of hone in on their final
version they might want to take a look
at that and decide whether whether the
user confusion is going to be worth the
benefits are getting out of it this is a
really interesting example as well where
you know given that it is in beta
there's an opportunity there to do some
a be testing and just you know sort of
pick one or a few different options
present in two different users and use
analytics to figure out which is the one
that people are finding the easiest to
use so I'm a big fan of doing that
particularly in beta just if you've got
a bunch of alternate ideas present them
all and see which one uses actually
using and find the most intuitive but
especially coming from their last
version which was you know as I said a
service that we usually we've always
enjoyed using the app but design-wise
this is head and shoulders above the
other one
so hopefully they'll uh they'll converge
onto something that everybody loves and
will you know we'll get all that figured
out the other thing of course and this
pretty much applies to almost any app
that has any kind of login is let's
integrate that sign in if you're not
going to do it with Google then
integrate with something else you know
Facebook's popular twitter is fine
anything where the user is likely to
have an account on the machine for
Android we usually suggest google not
because that's who pays us although it
sort of is but because almost all
Android devices have a Google account on
them yeah I mean really what we're just
trying to do is make that sign-in flow
as simple as possible and it's something
that we're particularly sensitive to
because we install a lot of apps and
we're doing this and you know the app
clinic apps off obviously we spend a
fair bit of time looking at but we spend
a lot of time looking at a lot of apps
and and you just want to we do it really
quickly you know will download it will
open it up and we want to figure out how
this app works what is doing right what
it's doing wrong inside of fifteen
seconds well you know I don't think
we're unique in that because I think
they representative it's very very
common if if a user wants to download an
app for a particular purpose it's
extremely common to download 10 of them
and the ones that are going to get
looked at first are the ones that don't
throw up any roadblocks to finding out
what the functionality is now groupme is
an app that I love a lot but I think I
probably would have skipped it at the
beginning because I couldn't get into
the app until I had not only put in my
phone number but their recent verified
it with an SMS which I never got now
fortunately they fixed that particular
flow but you still have to sign in
before you can get to the good stuff
absolutely and this you know it's
something which which actually I can see
in for next week where we're doing our
personal fitness apps and i actually
discovered this exact scenario where i
was sitting at the at the foot of the
mountain ready to go hiking my life's
like we should track how far we go I
think I have an app for that so I fired
up the trailer looked at all the
suggestions and installed each of them
and the way I chose which one to use was
i just opened them one at a time and as
soon as i got to a roadblock i stopped
and checked at the
one was quicker it's like you need me to
sign in no you need me to do a bunch of
settings um no and that's kind of the
way people use their apps they're going
I need to do something I'm going to
download an app and see whether it does
that for me it's not the yeah I've got
some time i'm going to download this app
and see what it does and see how it
works it's not really the use case
particularly on mobile and we're being a
little unfair because obviously in an
instant messaging situation you have to
sign it you have to sign in in some
identity but that's why that's why it's
so important to federate or integrate
with the context manager and the account
manager on the device now we'll say
Ingram's favor that their new beta if
you don't sign it immediately still has
a view pager with some demo screens on
it kind of tells you what you're getting
into see I think that's a good effort um
that's still you know if I could just
open it up and it automatically knew oh
you're this guy I think I've seen you
before that would make me super happy
absolutely and keep in mind as well that
even without doing the Federated sign in
the deans describing you can tell me
what my phone number is by checking the
phone and you can tell me what my email
address is by checking the phone and so
populating those and asking me to
confirm them rather than having me type
them all in is all things which are
going to make that sign-in process
smoother absolutely so what do you think
about trillion trillion so kind of
similar to to the first step that we
looked at in that I'd really like to see
a modernized UI and an improved tablet
support I think otherwise it's it's good
in that it has that focus and so that's
a big thing for me as an app which has a
clear focus and in this app they're not
trying to reinvent messaging they're
just trying to make it easy for you to
use the tools and the services and the
contacts which you've already been
communicating with on a different
platform well and I guess it's not
showing up here because this slide was
to put together by trained monkeys but
the real important thing I think is that
they should integrate with contacts
manager absolutely absolutely i've
already got my contacts there put all of
that data in there and that's going to
make life a lot easier so yeah I
basically trillions been around for a
long time and so that's why I think
tablet support is a big one for them
it's like it's a company which clearly
recognizes that there is an opportunity
in adapting their service to people
using new devices
but look let's adapt all the way let's
make it work by the way you didn't put
this slide together did you know that
was my trained monkeys oh good yeah good
yeah I think they getting there I mean
this is closed this is two out of three
yeah I'm pretty happy with that that's
true good point all right so I think
just on half an hour we've managed to
keep it to her to the time frame that we
were hoping to this week so yeah yes
that's all for us today don't forget to
tune into Roman Nick and Adam for
Android design in action next tuesday
from the uncluttered new york office
where they'll be setting their design
skills loose on some of the instant
messaging apps that we talked about
today and i think they said they're
going to be looking at tripit as well Oh
excellent yeah I was just talking to
Rome and then he said he had to go
because he was on the phone with a and
then he used it a nasty word no yeah
that's the better I think you know why
New York yeah New York is man anyway
we'll be back next week taking a look at
personal fitness tracking apps the
voting in that category has been fierce
so be sure to hit our Trello page and
get your votes and nominations in for
this week and the following weeks and
that's there's a bitly link there at bit
ly / app clinic Trella now remember to
vote early don't be like the people who
nominated poor glyph which received the
most votes this week but was nominated
too late to be considered we'll try and
squeeze glyph into another week but
until then here's a quick message to
tide you over pencil square skull skull
skull diamond airplane pencil nice one
until then I'm rato maya i'm ian
ni-lewis and thank you for watching
you